même si on parle beaucoup
d'environnements ces jours ci ce n'est
pas un enjeu qui fera changer d'avis les
électeurs selon un sondage léger menée
pour le devoir à la question au final
quels enjeux influencera le plus votre
vote l'économie les taxes arrivent loin
devant avec 43 % des réponses cet enjeu
est en tête dans toutes les provinces et
dans toutes les tranches d'âge les
enjeux sociaux et l'aide aux plus
démunis arrive au deuxième rang à 19%
l'environnement et la lutte contre les
changements climatiques suivent à 16%
le dernier choix proposés l'immigration
et l'identité récolte 7 % on en parle
avec alexandre gage et vic sayyed
professeur au département de science
politique à l'université laval
spécialiste des politiques climatiques
et environnementales suisses hayek
bonsoir bonsoir merci m'accueillir c'est
un plaisir les gens semblent prioriser
l'économie ou en tout cas les taxes la
prospérité économique dont à
l'environnement ou au changement
climatique est ce qui est ce qu'il est
possible selon vous d'assurer une bonne
ou prospérité économique tout en ayant
une bonne politique climatique
absolument c'est deux choses vont main
dans la main heureux aujourd'hui
oui mais encore regardez on parle en ce
moment de la transition vers une
économie verte c'est-à-dire de commandes
devrait assurer notre prospérité
économique tout en diminuant à nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre on
regarde qu'eux en ce moment on va devoir
par exemple prenons l'industrie
pétrolière et gazière
on va devoir assurer que beaucoup de
travailleurs vont migrer de cette
industrie polluante vers des nouvelles
industries des nouvelles technologies
alors si on pense cette transition en
amont on sera capable de conjuguer une
prospérité économique tout en diminuant
de nos gaz à effet de serre mais
commencer pour voir les opportunités
qu'il y a
à lutter contre les changements
climatiques tout à fait
il ya beaucoup de travail à faire en
tout cas décrivez-nous un peu puis on va
le voir dans le graphique l'état de la
situation dans nos réductions
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
jusqu'à maintenant
l'objectif est quand même grand faut
atteindre 517 mégatonnes pour baisser à
517 mégatonnes mais on est loin du
compte là exactement est-ce que vous
avez le graphique devant vous oui alors
ce qu'on remarque avec ce graphique
c'est que à mesure qu'on inclut de
nouvelles politiques on obtient des
nouvelles estimations alors c'est
intéressant de comparer par exemple en
la courbe bleue que vous avez halak avec
la courbe verte qui descend la courbe
verte
c'est à la cour but c'est celle où on
avait juste les mesures en place de
factoriser dans le calcul d'une
réduction la courbe verte c'est celle
qui inclut toutes les mesures du cadre
pancanadien pour les réductions de gaz à
effet de serre alors ce qu'il ya de
conclusion qu'on peut en tirer de ce
graphique là par exemple c'est que
d'abord d'un point de vue scientifique
on est loin du compte - même si on
inclut toutes ces mesures ce qui inclut
la tarification du carbone
alors ça c'est plutôt une conclusion
scientifique la conclusion politique
serait qu'on doit bonifier nos nos
politiques présentement on doit pas
abolir la taxe carbone on a là de rendre
plus robuste
on doit pas abolir les standards sur les
sur les carburants on doit les rendre
plus forts et ça d'ailleurs
ce graphique là dans le fond c'est comme
sur d'autres et 75 % de l'objectif est
atteint
c'est à dire 75% des mesures sont
identifiés ou en tout cas des objectifs
mais ça veut pas dire qu'on l'a atteint
là ça veut pas du tout dire qu'on a
atteint et on n'est pas du tout dans la
trajectoire de l'atteindre en ce moment
bon alors allons doit accélérer la
transition vers une économie verte
alors on a ici les endroits un autre
graphique les secteurs en quelque sorte
où nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sont son doudou elles proviennent
finalement il ça vient beaucoup du
pétrole gaz naturel et du transport
exactement ces deux secteurs la
représente déjà plus de la moitié mais
c'est vraiment très intéressant de
procéder par secteur adou vont venir nos
réductions d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre alors est-ce que si on regarde
vraiment d'où proviennent vos émissions
il ya quand même des conclusions qu'on
peut quand même
c'est à dire en ce moment si on ne
diminue pas notre secteur pétrolier et
gazier
on ne sera pas capable d'athènes aux
cibles qui sont de 45 % de réduction en
2030 je veux dire même si on conduisait
on était tous végétariens avec des
voitures électriques
on ne serait pas capable d'atteindre
aussi ben alors on doit avoir une
diminution progressive mais constante de
nos secteurs pétrolier et gazier
aussi on devrait commencer d'ailleurs
pas ce secteur là aussi par le secteur
de l'électricité et le secteur des
transports
parce que ce sont les secteurs qu'on a
déjà les technologies pour faire ce
virage alors ce serait déjà trois des
secteurs qui devraient prioriser dans
cette transition mais ça me ramène à ma
première question comment on conjugue la
prospérité économique quand on sait
l'importance du pétrole du gaz naturel
de l'énergie dans notre économie
comment on fait pour continuer à croître
ne pas supprimer des emplois ne pas
créer d récession tout en ayant une
politique climatique robuste
c'est extrêmement important qu en
question je commencerai par d'ailleurs
identifié quelque chose
un plan plus politique c'est à dire on
devrait avoir en place un bureau pour
une transition juste alors on devrait
avoir en place un bureau qui est dédié à
comprendre l'impact que cette transition
là va voir son nom ménage sur nos
travailleurs sont nos industries sur nos
investissements
alors comment alors la vérité c'est que
c'est on a besoin de beaucoup plus
d'études
à ce niveau la peau pour qu'on puisse
vraiment identifier l'impact sur chacun
de ces personnes de notre société
par contre il ya déjà des mesures très
clair qu'on peut identifier
d'abord d'abord et avant tout on doit
penser à des mesures de soutien et de
formation pour les travailleurs qui vont
passer d'un secteur polluants vers des
secteurs non polluants on doit aussi
penser à l'impact que les politiques
climatiques vont avoir sur des ménages
là par exemple on devrait parler un peu
de tarification du carbone si vous
permettez
ben oui ben justement j'allais vous
poser cette question là déjà on est à 20
ou 25 dollars la tonne présentement puis
bon
j'en trouve que ça coûte déjà trop cher
et justement la vérité c'est que ça doit
coûter plus cher pour qu'on réussisse à
atteindre nos cibles alors la
tarification du carbone
c'est une mesure qui est nécessaire mais
c'est pas une mesure qui est suffisante
alors évidemment ça va prendre beaucoup
d'autres mesures comme justement les
standards sur le méthane les standards
pour le carburant les incitatifs pour
les technologies vertes alors ça va
prendre toute une série d'autres mesures
mais la tarification du carbone est
peut-être la politique la plus centrale
parce qu'elle envoie un message à toute
l'économie a quasiment tout les secteurs
au québec elle couvre 4 80% de
l'économie québécoise alors c'est très
important par contre comment on peut
faire ça de manière juste parce que la
vérité c'est que c'est pas vrai que tous
les ménages peuvent subir cette
augmentation là alors on devrait très
proactifs dans notre explication de ce
qu'est la tarification du carbone en
fait on devrait être en tant que société
cédée dans cette communication politique
politique là mais il devrait être très
clair que les ménages vont payer plus à
la pompe mais pas dans leur budget mais
certains segments sondages aujourd'hui
d'un épisode pour global où on posait la
question combien de vous prêt à dépenser
personnellement par année aux taxes
hausses de coûts pour les biens et
services pour aider à la lutte contre
les changements climatiques
46% des gens disent 0 $ donc il ya un
enjeu de communication et de conviction
et de soutien aux familles qui doivent
payer la taxe carbone la tarification
tout à fait mais la plupart des familles
ne devraient pas payer rien pour cette
transition là c'est possible d'avoir
cette transition soit pliée par exemple
le plan fédéral actuel redonne 70% des
familles reçoit plus que ce que ce
qu'ils payent c'est à dire donc en ce
moment ces familles là sont même avec un
prix sur le carbone
ils reçoivent davantage d'argent alors
ce qu'on fait avec l'argent de la
tarification du carbone est extrêmement
important justement d'un point de vue de
la justice et de combinations de
prospérité et et lutte contre les
changements climatiques
une deuxième chose justement attend
d'elle oui ben pour cet argent là
justement devrait servir à d'autres
mesures de justice c'est à dire
l'investissement dans les transports en
commun qui
certes la population en général les
rénovations verte qui servent aussi la
population en général alors la
population devrait sortir gagnante du
seuil est qu'on s'arrête là dessus c'est
très intéressant c'est un débat
important
merci à la prochaine ça fait plaisir à
la prochaine